[Music]
okay so this is my review of your honor
episode four
this is the first episode not directed
by edward berger
this one is directed by clark johnson
and written by
david matthews so it's a strange open
because the way they left the
cliffhanger from last episode with
kofi going to see carlo baxter
you thought something might actually
come more of this and he's just
dead which was the original expected
result from earlier in that episode
carlo kills him but you see jimmy baxter
was not happy about
carlo doing this he said he had it taken
care of but carlo calls him out like
no you didn't and that he was listening
to his mother
gina so this is where jimmy's seeing
that gina's kind of going behind his
back and
giving orders but what this episode
develops with gina baxter and jimmy
baxter
is that as we already know gina baxter
really is like the mastermind here and
the
actually most dangerous threat but she's
getting
the monster out of her husband she's
giving him his mojo back
to get out of this sulking and start
doing things which we'll see by the end
of this episode
that monster fully combs she's just
constantly poking this beast now when we
switch gears to
michael and adam's story in this episode
we see michael say to adam that
kofi's death had nothing to do with him
or adam
and this gets payoff by the end because
we'll really get into michael's
headspace by the end of this episode
when he's fighting with adam outside
and adam says can you just once admit
what really happened and michael
actually is starting to believe the lie
and this false reality he's created
he is far down the rabbit hole and he's
again his motivations constantly just
make sure
his son is protected and has a normal
life
what i like about michael and charlie's
relationship because when he goes to see
charlie
charlie's doing just as bad things as
michael here but charlie's at least
admitting it and he's a realist about it
where this is kind of what michael
doesn't want to hear
and it's just truth serum he always
hears from charlie like yeah this is
what we're doing
and you got me involved so suck it up
but like michael's just still in this
denial part of it because he doesn't
want to like realize
fully that he got kofi killed and
charlie's like look well you can't mess
this up
now you can't just go to the police
about this or do something about this
because
then it's my butt on the line so it's
just more of a predicament
that michael has got himself into but it
also gives some kind of justifications
to keep lying in his own head to protect
charlie's running for mayor and
obviously protecting his son
now a little twist and surprise here was
when adam goes to see
his teacher frannie and she says
sometimes there
are truths worth lying for so this is
a surprise because he went to franny
last episode
confessing what he did sharing this
burden with her
and adam was surprised and not happy
about this reaction we get this episode
from her because
he was kind of looking at her to be the
opposite of his dad and
be a way out for him to maybe get this
out in the right way
and she's the same mindset as the father
like justifying it and that
she's pretty good with holding a lie
here so that's an interesting turn of
events for her character which i like i
think that makes that story a little
interesting
with adam and franny but where this
episode kind of
runs into problems especially with
pacing is when
michael and lee go to kofi's family
to inform them what's happened to kofi
it just kind of becomes static
and i would argue that the first half of
this episode
is static and i wish it picked up a
little bit more and
it doesn't really get going until this
dinner scene in the last 20 minutes
i understand the point of the scene with
them going to kofi's family
and she's really reiterating the part of
how corrupt these cops are and the
police lying
but it's a little dragged out and
there's a lot of scenes here in this
episode that
you could start to feel your zoning out
a bit while you're watching because
last episode did such a good job of
developing all these different conflicts
and different parties involved and what
could happen and mess up michael's plan
or this episode
at least the first half was more just
everything was kind of reactionary to
what happened to kofi but it was
not enough conflict or interest here or
maybe some of these scenes could have
been sacrificed and where in my head i
think
things could have been a little chopped
up here was especially with gina
baxter's story
where it was really good last episode
but a little cringy here because
the catalyst to get jimmy baxter
to be himself again is her also calling
him out
not sticking up for her and their faith
to their daughter it all just felt a lot
of silly writing here where she's saying
to jimmy
she's turning from god you said nothing
and then you brought
our boy a motorcycle and then you did
nothing and where i really didn't like
her writing was
when she's talking to jimmy and she's
just going on this little monologue
about
new orleans where she's like we have
stoops in front of our houses so that
what passes
on the streets can be heard and she's
like this city is waiting to him it's a
little
too mellow dramatic here and over the
top where that writing
did not feel like the realistic writing
of the rest of the show
of how the characters talking felt like
very theatrical i just don't feel they
needed this
extra little subplot here of fia baxter
being anti-religion to push jimmy to the
next level and
use that as a ploy to get him going now
what i do like about the subplot with
michael
and lee's relationship is that she's
this dangerous thing that if she
finds out what's really happening can
screw up everything but
michael needs lee because it's this one
thing that's keeping him
somewhat sane during all this and giving
him joy but it's like
serving this fake reality and life he's
created in his head and on top of bad
scenes that
again could have just been made more a
little realistic or cut
altogether was this scene with adam in
the hallway with his friend
and his friend said he's gonna send a
sexual picture to franny
and he just pushes him in the locker and
they start fighting that was ridiculous
this is an overblown reaction by adam
yeah he's going through a lot but
for that to be the thing that triggers
him when his friend clearly doesn't know
anything about his relationship with
franny just seemed
off and again a silly scene i feel like
you could have written a better way
to get the grandma of adam into this
story
so we see though this is another problem
for michael
is his mother-in-law elizabeth the
senator
and adam just does a another really
stupid thing in the many stupid things
he's done in this show but
this was one of the worst where he's
like yeah there is a cop that still
was always had my mom's back and that's
nancy costello i'll give you her number
and she should come over this is the
main
person who's gonna be a threat to
michael and adam and is the one closest
to kind of catching on to what's really
going on so this is just like
stupidity on adam's part you just roll
your eyes as an audience member but the
moment when elizabeth mentions to
michael
why didn't you call me on robin's death
day there was no flowers
nothing this is where stuff starts to
pick up the last 20 minutes because it
now is a catalyst to michael being on
edge again
and this dinner party where everything
just kind of gets wild
and on top of that lee shows up so this
is the worst case scenario for michael
because now you have all these parties
he's got to perform in front of
everybody now
and the problem that happens here is
that adam learns more he learns about
kofi's torture
and every party here learns more that
they didn't know with the senator
learning about just kofi being related
to robin's car in general
and of course that bloody rag comes into
play now the dog finds
but michael has to talk himself out of
that rag quickly change the subject to
how him and adam should have been more
honest and open to everybody
but this leads to another scene that the
writing is good here
but the directing choice here to have
them right outside of the house where
they have to be
secretive saying these big things really
loud
if you're gonna do this scene have them
at least whisper fight and argue here
they're just
at the top of the lungs saying things
that if anyone
just with an ear shot that dinner party
heard them would ruin everything that
was crazy to me especially because we
know how
on top of and paranoid michael is of
everything that he wouldn't be like
adam shut up like say that lower like
they would be whispering fires that was
just an odd directing
flub up in my opinion but you see adam's
gonna call out michael for his hypocrisy
because michael's like why would you
bring grandma around
why are you getting these people here
like nancy castell involved but he's
like you're the one dating a lawyer who
could really screw us
so that's part of the selfishness of
michael here where he's so
rule based on what adam can do during
this to protect them but he's not
checking in on himself all the time and
breaking his own little rules
and that ego coming in here is like
where i decide what the truth is now
he's not really ever listening to adam
and what adam has to say about what they
should do
and i love that line that i had
referenced before where adam says to
michael can't you just once admit what
really happened
ed michael literally says the story he's
made up in his head now a gang member
stole our car was involved in a hit and
run he was tortured by the police pled
guilty and died in jail that's all he's
deciding to believe at this point
i mean if you're adam you gotta just be
freaked out by this at this point and i
like the line here with michael talking
elizabeth later on he's like
people lie for certain reasons every day
but not all those reasons are bad ones
saying about adam with why their flowers
weren't there that day that
his line couldn't be better motivated so
this is a direct reflection on how he
views his lie and adam's lie together
that it is justified and motivated and
you see it was like is that something
you want to teach your son
well-motivated lying but he brings up
this running routine that's very strange
he has about counting
the parked cars and then when a car that
actually passes him
lined up that's when he knows how many
years adam's got
left to live and it's just reiterating
again this character of michael the core
of his motivation
is to protect his son's future and give
a good life for him at all
costs and that is why he thinks it is a
good cause the lying he is doing now
where he's ignoring he is super
responsible for the death of
kofi already and messing up people's
lives and it's going to get worse
because now we get this crazy moment at
the end here where
the monster has been unleashed of jimmy
baxter by gina baxter
the mastermind behind all this and she
uses jimmy as her
her chest piece to get done what needs
to be done
and he blows up kofi's family house
and there's only his little brother left
and sadly he sees us
this is going to be huge because we do
not know
how adam and michael are gonna react to
this
that now the whole family's dead and
that blood
is on their hands now out of the first
four episodes was my least favorite
because i
really thought the first half had a lot
of scenes that just were not great like
i had said and then it was a
very very crawl slow pace here
and i wasn't so crazy too how they went
about with like a cliffhanger last
episode leading into just a
anti-climatic open which is seeing a
dead kofi here
but the score i give it will go up a bit
because it again had a really strong
last 20 minutes
in particular the big reveal of the
house blowing up and
this dinner scene so i'm gonna give this
one a 7.9
we still got six episodes to go so i
hope they keep this
interesting but pick up the pace a bit
especially where they struggle in these
first half hours of episodes where just
get some of the flub out here but i'm
worried this is going to be a trend
because it is 10 episodes and that was
already worth some of the kind of story
this is
where again you know already what
happened in the beginning so you're kind
of seeing a dad
get through all this but i don't know if
stretching a story like that
works great with 10 episodes maybe this
would have been better fit seven
episodes and again cutting some of these
filler scenes but we'll see
let me know what you thought of this
episode down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment and try to
respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of your
honor i also review a bunch of other tv
shows movies and i do celebrity
interviews as well
and if you really like what i do here it
would help me so much if you were to
donate two dollars a month there's a
link down below
it's a paypal link that will help me do
more videos for you guys and be able to
do this
time and please follow me at steve
barley show on twitter instagram for
more of me
and i'll see you next time